previously on we need to go deeper whoa
the atomic i'm buying it you can't speak
to the captain that way i'm a fun
captain this is a pleasure cruise oh
how was i supposed to know
gab needs a few smooches if you know
what i mean
you got it gonna take a nap in the
drilldo bed munition sites you have
lasers on your guns
what happens
whoa
you can run into things when it's purged
but that's invinci that's solid
invincibility feel free to run into
anything
captain's got an idea call this uh the
my skirm drift
oh
i'm going in the cave
oh my god okay who knows where it is in
sightless
you're hitting it
[Music]
aimed up john you aim down yeah we'll
catch him on the return wait i'm gonna
look at the coming from south it's
coming below oh
okay he's hurting all right i'll let you
know bottom bottom bottom middle oh oh i
can't turn that quick
okay
i'll just keep aim down then yeah
what's happening
oh god i forgot i forgot everybody oh
[ __ ] oh we're on fire
for fire oh god we're on fire
all right he's
okay coming back online
one two
skip to my lou
you could even maybe turn the engines
off
yeah that probably is a good idea give
me two guns everything
and if we get into repair trouble
there's a hole in the pilot's room okay
so
i'm gonna watch the purge i will watch
the purge
okay well it's now the time for the move
yeah you push up in the middle okay
where is he
where is he
show yourself honestly honestly if we
purge when he hits it probably is gonna
do good i'm back now so i'm good does he
not come after us if we're not moving
oh because he's the sightless he he was
on our own oh okay all right i'll kick
some edges we need an engine yeah okay
okay so i have to i have to pilot still
okay all right get ready purge is coming
up
three two
almost there we go
touch us now
look at the damage
oh god there is doable
that was a lot of damage what happened
he when we have the invincibility shield
he
yeah
okay
you got it got it got it you got it
where's that other hole
hole somewhere not on me not up top
one's dead one dead
that is really nice
okay yeah no i'm ready for that that's
fine
oh never mind we deserve this dinner
yeah i can't tell if you deserve it or
not i don't know who
you with your secret food what do you
mean the captain has their privacy two
glasses of wine and a close
jesus okay
i'm sorry that wasn't very chill of me
yeah we kind of lost our head there for
a second
it's my fault that's fine all right guys
remember it's chill it's good it's good
i think we're in the board ocean from
hour alone
look if we if we want to give uh
the skadoosh power possible i'm i'm
gonna be the boss a pad
maybe we could better
[ __ ] her out with some guns i don't know
all right well we're just here longer to
get hit
you're right you're right
he's got a point
wade what say you it is your right now
it's shooting uh you're the captain
captain i go with you
i say punch it i say punch it
no guns for you
it's all on my shoulders let's do this
it's a boost oh god oh god
oh no
we're gonna hit again captain what we're
gonna boost it straight to hell
fine it's fine that was just a
sub-optimal boost moment oh captain
you know what we're out of here [ __ ] you
guys all right that's what i'd like to
hear
oh
we still have a dent somewhere captain
uh
schmann surfer pens
what where the dance dude called your
name
who are you trying to
get a full chomp on
and then you go straight down
let's see if this gets tonight
no nibble our giblets now idiot
down right
or down left either
the look of that either
we're fine this is fine you're about to
get sucked
oh yeah i am laughing cave
yes
we may not have any money oh never mind
the underseal
slightly more than you are girly which
is not very much where i am i'm dead
you should probably do that
oh i need to open a door at the back of
the lair okay oh the laser the laser is
wait a minute a gun
oh no don't fist me i don't need no way
laser i'm going left side right side is
safer
there we go
oh he don't have no arms
you don't have no arms
oh now he's easy what you gotta do now
you stompy a-hole
i don't know if i can shoot him in the
head he's going to just
don't stay under him i think it just
triggers his whole body oh can i heal
can i heal
no he's weak on the head
the wrench stairway he is whoa
yes i think that's a gun for the ship
that's going to kill me
there's also two guns on the ground over
to the right there but a revolver
and also a flintlock
i'm going to take the revolver i don't
wait i don't like was there going for
the shipper for you how's it going the
one that the guy dropped was a gun for
the ship hmm
everybody on the over here in the cave
no sir i managed to find a way up to
nowhere never mind it said
all right the captain is confused and is
going to hit the engine aren't you
captain punching it punch it chewie
whoever's not here doesn't deserve
captaining you're right
maybe i'll give you guys a chance to use
those guns baby
okay use your use your fuel bob
i tried to conserve it for what i really
needed and not just want to go fast for
no reason it's not for no reason
it's pretty much no reason
wait
cave left
[Applause]
[Music]
good one captain your jokes are the
funniest ones there's a named crab over
here where'd you go
yeah what's your name make him nameless
steve the skittish
don't worry
it's dead that's what it is oh we're
[ __ ] schooling these two
the
there's more space pigs look out i mean
ocean pigs
ocean bars ocean space old bores ores
look out for the oars they're all dead
all right
are they up there are they make a trophy
good expedition got a battery right we
got a battery we do and you know where
i'm going to slap this
i have a guess
ghost crab
i got him don't worry everybody back on
the ship yes sir
[Music]
here we go i'm still going to give you
guns boys
any sort of navigational information
whatsoever there's a uh something
all right another place to stop i'm
going into the head
into the totem head
fix skateboard
permission
[Applause]
a water poop
another battery a water pump and a long
range rifle
oh we want the right we have enough
money for the right
[Music]
i got 3.85 we could buy it we could buy
it we could buy it what are we buying
right let's try it let's try i'll i'll
dump all i have that's all i got that's
all you got that's not a good start big
stocks
that's me okay okay making moves making
moves
this is it
accurate don't worry money bags coming
in huh
shotgun rifle supreme nuclear remember
let's make brain happy pleasure cruise
it's meant to be pleasurable
sniper
pompom surely this does more damage
right sure
and don't call me shirley
pleasure cruise
all right what boss is this what are we
doing here what are we doing we are
running shell
two minutes hot oh i'm gonna go whoa
whoa
that was whoa
confusing i didn't realize that he was
moving and no i didn't know that that
was weird yeah it's quickly going down
oh we're just doing a lot of damage
all right we're gonna almost do our
boost we've got two
shields so don't worry and then once
this happens when i do this boost run
into them okay
all right ready
i got hang on uh ready three
two
one there we go
all right that one did not hurt him very
much all right
i think we gotta only shoot him in the
head
yeah i think so oh god do we not have
engines we have engines
okay we just like weren't moving for a
hot second it was very scary
gonna hurt us it's just gonna blow us
around it's fine okay i don't mind a
good blowing
nice nice purge nice
nice purge
nice purge there it is that's the one
ah meal time
next is the epic upgrade of the day last
grandfather it's me
or is it just me
myself
i probably repair real good now
watercolor
clear submarine is safe for us
baby it's radiation you fool of course
it's safe oh goodness
you're fine after that are we drifting
or regular cruising uh middle cruising
two cruise holes
dude there's flowers
they're pretty close your cruise got
more pleasurable you guys didn't believe
me
the pleasure begins now
pleasure
where do i go where do i go
oh god that's bad too
it might be time to drift all right
first we're doing this
then we're doing this
and we are drifting out of here
see you later space time continuum oh we
should have a shield we should have
doubled
oh i'm dying there's a crocodile in the
basement yep no i'm in the hole
that's all right
i'm taking one of these i don't know
which gun i just stole from
i think we oh god that's a big isle
captain there's a cave i'm caving
that's a big good idol
that's not good
can i be men kidding i think i'm growing
tentacles go sleep in the drill doe bed
oh pretty good everybody good oh we're
moving this door's like
shut oh there we go okay
that was terrifying there's money whoa
backpack up here
am i the last one to not have a backpack
oh no i snagged one without telling
anybody in their last cake oh
i need i need health where is ba
where's backpack what's up when you go
up first
wow that is weird
that is weird new item appeared in the
catalog you guys didn't pick up the
helmet don't mind me whoa
no
down here
oh
guys i don't like it it's fine
he's powering on ahead also there's an
upside down name because there's an
upside down character oh god no there's
i'm bad
i'm refreezing
here have some love thank you
pow pow health health
let's take this sketch
oh there is oopsy doopsies all right
another big one great
oh god guys i found something would you
found something
i'm unsure but it looks kind of like a
jet pack
it looks like a jet pack it probably is
i can't seem to oh my god you guys i
have a jet pack whoa no we only got
stinky backpacks
also there's a big needle down here
a big needle
yeah i think it's a weapon i'm unsure
all right how did you get down there
there was a big down and i went it
please here oh my goodness
i have four five six seven eight and
you're so good to your captain
horse captain is that a hat cap
where are you i'm in the basement of the
cave there's a basement
i don't know down
no further explanation i have to offer
captain i'm sorry
perfect directions look at my jet pack
clear
whoa
he has a jet pack oh we're killing an
ancient guy that's not very nice well
now he's dead no he's not look i'm going
to jet pack over him while we murder him
wow
i need heals the wonders of modern
technology ladies and gentlemen i can
give him radiation poisoning take the
skittish's back
oh no
he's so skittish
yeah you should have seen click the
skittish he's half the skittish cheek
ever was
don't you say that about click
why can't i oh i have to crawl through
here
get him oh my god this is ah
too many it is the coolest cave we've
been in yet like it's really heals
thank you
thank you of course captain no problem
captain i need a little insect
oh no
no no no
whatever the hell is fossilized
upside down man i don't know
it's sir mclaughlin sarah mclachlan no
no there could be only one
die away
from here don't worry guys i'll just fly
above all the danger every day five take
the skittishes get killed by sea
explorers it's gonna be so sad if that
jackpot runs out of fuel
there's nothing indicating that it does
i just i am a jet pack man now
you guys want to know what's at the top
of this
nothing you're welcome all right
thank you but we never would have known
if not for the jet pack
incredibly useful actually you forever
know the wonders of nothing
uh
all right but i'll know
i'm back on board i feel like that's all
there is to this
i'm inside captain can i fly i can fly
in the ship too
incredible
well fly our ship happen look
please drive
oh my god we need repairs captain all
right straight down it is
no we don't uh we were shaking
that's from the impacts oh oh oh i don't
want to go over there i changed my
opinion
i'm running i'm using all of my fuels
sounds like we're getting hit a lot
there's a thing it's not good thing
outside
this is the maximum amount of fleeing
we've done yet lads please
no one flees like we do now we have a
leak
oh we have several
they're getting fixed
all right i actually burned through
can i get a little more
or a little more killing oh
if one of the guns has power and isn't
being used please give it to me
i don't remember which guys which but
i'm always safe
oh god there's monsters in the basement
okay
this crocodile really means business oh
my god good job fellaini what are you
talking about
fighting this crocodile there we go ow
thanks y'all want to hit up this
bubblegum shrimp
is this another cave normal cave
maybe yeah this is just a regular place
it's raining lobster crabs oh i'm going
to fly above the danger captain
i'm going ball deep i picked up an
eldritch staff
beware
captain
beware
oh wait i haven't tried my here
have some syringe oh thank you you guys
need some syringe what does that do yes
actually i need more i need more there
you go here's some syringe for you does
that do anything good i think what are
the heels what are we addicted to right
now
i don't know man but good [ __ ] right oh
there's another jet pack down here
captain so close bob go up there and get
it
push me captain would you like a jet
pack
i would
but my eldest
oh my god you can have both you can have
it all
oh my god beware my staff of doom
bastards oh my god
good use of the word captain
careful with that thing captain oh my
god you're just flying around everywhere
zapping them oh my god they died so
quick i think i need to see beyond
exploration with this newfound power
we're better out of the sub than we are
in it all right well that was fun
backpacks away
there's a thing there's a thing over
here
do you guys want to see this cool chest
area oh well that's no that's cool
kidding
good luck getting healed
i have a syringe and the captain has
something probably do you have the heels
oh god i summoned an eldritch demon with
my staff
it backfired
okay i found another area that's kind of
a jet package thank you thank you thank
you yes of course you just had enemies
there oh hey what's up kill him killing
his weird mouse whoa hey what's up
i'm back uh my my jet pack also flew me
up wow you gotta make the noise with
your mouth i'm actually uh above the jet
pack
i had a jet pack when i was a kid i
don't need one anymore we need to find a
place to spend our money i'm rich again
yeah i'm rich i think the bigger issue
is going to be finding a place where we
don't die okay i think we need to do the
zoomies zoomies
all right nuking
do i go down here is this the way yeah
double shields i like how our guns look
like you guys are sticking sawed off
shotguns outside oh civilization what is
that
i don't want to go to the ocean mushroom
civilization oh yeah
all right let's show them our cool
technology get out your jet packs
oh it's the perfect jet pack place you
gotta climb a ladder
[Music]
no we need to go deeper not higher oh
hold up upgrade all upgrade he'll
upgrade well we probably we probably
want that can we afford it
it means when you burn fuel
yeah i bet it does it's fart oh i'm
jumping into the top of the fuel i'm
gonna get i'm gonna buy the tires as the
driver and the fuel consumer i'm on it
oh you're on it never mind sir go for it
finish it i'll buy it with a slight
investment
nice does everyone have a backpack now
yes
oh sorry i thought you said jet pack
wait
[ __ ] why didn't why did you just shoot
them what i didn't i saw a sword stab
somebody just shooted our friends oh no
well let's get out of here before they
get back
oh lord
just stood there happily okay i like how
we're going deeper into the ocean and
somehow we found a surface-dwelling
civilization they live in a dome
oh it's a dome
right that's what the muslims want oh
i'm with you now i'm with you i'm
totally waiting
stick to drive in are you with me
well we sink quicker everybody boat yeah
i think like her too that's what i'm
saying ladders are bad going up bad
going down it's good
shut up man left back you're down
left down might be the boss area
are we zooming we are we have 60 health
that's cool that was a good hole upgrade
that was a good hull upgrade and just
wait for the toxic fuel all right here
we go here we go
chill don't wait up chill chill chill
not doing anything why are we really
engine
the ship i can repair and fight i have
the elder staff of the gods
didn't you be fighting then out here no
i know there's things inside at the
moment i'm almost to school i have five
health this guy's alive i'm coming back
i'm going up i'm involved
captain
oh
yes what
captain's not on board you're alone
killing you healing you oh god oh [ __ ]
we only have 18 health on the ship oh my
god
oh god i'm going back i'm going back oh
no no no no no it's not like this oh god
like this someone with the right
you did it
[Music]
no no no we're fine we're fine we're
fine i'm at three hours i don't
we're so fine someone please give me
something oh god get back
my
away
hit the doors you can open the doors by
hitting them man i guess i was supposed
to stay on this ship huh
i thought you said you weren't
i
had to be honest
captain's privilege
[Music]
yeah that's true that thing definitely
died there we killed it good job guys
well done sadly i think that might be it
for me boys no no i uh veto as captain
well i'll roll the i'll spin the wheel
and if it's you you can veto it all
right
i'm spinning
oh it's bob bob's captain uh veto oh
wait oh no no i guess you can leave if
you gotta go see your stupid mom or
whatever
[Music]
you